[Music]
it's hard to believe but Kingdom Hearts
3 is finally out this long-awaited
adventure has a lot going for it that'll
please fans while also potentially
attracting folks who may have avoided
the series and its myriad spin-offs over
the years regardless of your background
there are several tips you'll need to
know should you decide to embark on this
magical Disney filled adventure the tips
we've compiled will help prepare you for
the challenges that lie ahead in Kingdom
Hearts 3 for others they'll reinforce
and refresh your memory of the general
habits to follow around getting the most
out of its most well-established
mechanics we even included a fair amount
on some of the new things you'll
encounter without spoiling too many of
the surprises of course so let's get
onto it
[Music]
as you progress your party constantly
learns new abilities most of which you
have to activate manually take time to
jump into the abilities screen to
activate them so you don't miss out on
the useful perks they offer in some
instances you might even learn an
ability that's required to progress
further so don't neglect it just make
sure you're properly managing your
abilities and setting up the ones you're
more likely to use as each ability does
have a cost that takes up your overall
ap threshold
[Music]
we got this the more you all upon
enemies the more special tax you can use
during a fight you might not know it but
you can actually cycle through which
attacks you can activate by simply
pressing the trigger buttons make use of
this to open up your strategic options
in the fight reserving special tax for
moments where they matter
[Music]
once you're able to prepare meals with
Remy be sure to cook up one of each dish
type this allows you to eat a full
course in the cuisine menu which gives
you a temporary special ability bonus
along side a buff to your stats to
ensure you have enough to cook with
always scour the environment for
potential ingredients break open boxes
shatter lanterns or raid some leftover
Chinese takeout do whatever you got to
do
you can also buy ingredients at the
moogle shop and Sora Donald and Goofy
will even inform you whenever there's
ingredients around my bet we'll find
some ingredients around here hope we
find some ingredients around here
as long as you're paying attention you
should be well stocked before long check
up on the menu frequently too as more
recipes will unlock as you gather more
ingredients in addition if you keep
cooking Uncle Scrooge will give you
special item rewards for completing
dishes on the menu
[Music]
you can equip up to three key blades in
Kingdom Hearts 3 as you unlock more make
sure to mix and match to see which
combination works best for you or for
the enemy types you're fighting in a
particular world it's typically smart to
equip key blades with contrasting form
changes in order to give you more
options for example the favorite
deputies varied close-range attacks
mesh well with the projectiles of a
shooting star and this is more of a
personal preference but we recommend
always having the Kingdom key in your
loadout as it provides the best balance
of them all its form change second form
is also useful given its extended combo
that and if you're a classic Kingdom
Hearts fan it doesn't make sense being
without it always check in at the moogle
shop not only to purchase potions ethers
and equipment but also to upgrade your
key blades and synthesize materials you
need the proper materials to upgrade a
keyblade so make sure you're constantly
collecting enemy drops and scouring the
environment for treasure chests it's a
lot of effort but worth it to enhance
the magic strengths and abilities of
your weapon on the other hand
synthesizing materials is useful for a
variety of reasons while you can utilize
this feature to craft healing potions
and other power-ups you'll generally
want to use it to craft armor
accessories and valuable materials for
upgrading key blades if you lack the
money to purchase equipment there's
typically a lot of powerful pieces you
can synthesize that'll either close the
gap or help you specialize your stats
further the moogle shop frequently
accompanies save points for a good
reason
so make a habit of checking it to see if
you can upgrade Sora and company
[Music]
the moogle shop may have plenty of items
and accessories to synthesize but
there's several that aren't made
available to you unless you complete the
mughals photo challenges these mini
quests require you to take photographs
of specific locales and enemy types
check in every once in a while to see
what snapshots the moogle needs as
you're often rewarded with new synthesis
recipes upon completing them usually for
accessories that are far better than the
standard ones listed
[Music]
this should be a given but make sure
you're jumping into the item screen to
use all the boost items for your stats
you earn throughout your adventure these
allow you to enhance your party stats
further outside of simply leveling up or
enhancing their equipment we generally
recommend handing off all the AP once
the Soraa as he gets access to far more
abilities than Donald and Goofy while
all the rest you can divvy up based on
how you want to build up your party
stats of course avoid giving these
boosts to temporary party members for
obvious reasons oh I'll lucky annalen
you learn early on in your adventure
about lucky emblems which are Mickey
Mouse symbols that you're encouraged to
photograph with your gummy phone the
reward for photographing Lucky emblems
isn't made entirely clear at first but
know that doing so will net you the
secret ending if that entices you then
we encourage you to always be on the
lookout Sora Donald and Goofy often note
when the Lucky emblem is nearby so take
the time to investigate hey I think
that's a lucky emblem let's see they're
usually hidden behind objects on walls
or somewhere up above if you're
struggling be sure to check out our
in-depth lucky emblem video guide
we're not gonna lie Kingdom Hearts has a
wacky story that's sometimes difficult
to understand and if you're someone
who's missed out on a few of the
spin-offs over the years you might feel
lost at times playing Kingdom Hearts 3
luckily the game has story summary
videos that offer a crash course on
everything you need to know before
playing including details on the major
players conflicts and history access
these videos from the memory archive
option in the main menu
we highly recommend giving them a look
so that you understand Kingdom Hearts as
story beats and characters better
if you're a longtime fan of Kingdom
Hearts you'll want to partake in the
battle gate mode that unlocks towards
the end of the game it's an optional
mode where you can take on difficult
combat challenges each has a star
difficulty rating ranging from 1 to 3
and can be pretty tough but we recommend
doing these challenges as completing
them earns you special reports much like
the ansan reports from the first two
Kingdom Hearts games that flesh out the
story further in addition you get new
selfie poses so if that doesn't entice
you then we don't know what will and
that's all the tips we've got if you've
got any that we didn't discuss here be
sure to leave them in the comments below
thanks for watching
you